e aí
oi boa tarde quase né
e é muito bom quando a gente é convidado
a falar de amor
e eu estou muito confortável hoje para
poder falar desse tema que para mim tem
um impacto muito grande
e eu sempre tive o sonho em ser mãe a
maternidade ela sempre esteve presente
na minha família e no meu meio então
isso era uma certeza que era plena na
minha vida
como cuidar de uma criança amar proteger
isso era o que a maternidade
representava para mim
oi gente certa forma é isso que
representa mesmo
tá bom nem tudo acontece como a gente
planeja e as coisas elas na maioria das
vezes elas convergem para nos mostrar
que algo mais especial daquilo que
planejamos pode acontecer em nossas
vidas
oi e aí naturalmente eu me casei me
organizei né para ter uma família lá
tudo certinho até aí tudo bem o tempo
foi passando os anos também a gravidez
não acontecia
é mas enfim cada coisa no seu tempo
então somos também no embalo desse tempo
é mas aí o tempo já estava correndo
demais acho que talvez o relógio
biológico que toda mulher tem e até
então eu nem acreditava que existia de
fato começou a pulsar
e sim como o tempo passou ea gravidez
não aconteceu nós tomamos uma decisão
então passamos a investigar o motivo que
nós não conseguimos ter um filho
o que passamos por diversos
especialistas vários procedimentos
drogas né medicações procedimentos fora
um diagnóstico e foi dado núbia na
verdade a senhora não tem nada
biologicamente falando a senhora pode
engravidar naturalmente tranquilos
saímos dali muito felizes e aí
confiantes de que essa tão sonhada
gravidez iria acontecer
oi e aí como nós somos de um interior
muito menor do que vitória da conquista
era muito natural isso acontece com
muitas famílias que existam uma cobrança
uma indagação né uma curiosidade por
parte daquelas pessoas que estão no seu
ciclo para saber o motivo que você não
engravidou você deseja tanto você fala
tanto por que que você não tem filhos
você espere o seu marido
e essas e outras indagações foram
ouvidas ao longo de quase 11 anos
oi e daí 7 dias um telefonema então muda
o rumo das nossas vidas da minha e do
meu esposo
é uma pessoa liga para nossa residência
naquela ocasião ainda era telefone
chamado e aí diz assim olha existe uma
família que está à procura de pais
adotivos vocês não gostariam de eles
fazer uma visita aí eu disse como assim
uma visita eu acho que nem compreendi
direito aquilo que estavam me falando ao
telefone mas de pronta imediato eu disse
olha eu preciso consultar o meu esposo e
te dou um retorno de tão talvez perplexa
que eu estava com aquela situação
inesperada e aí meu esposo chegou e eu
mencionei a ele sobre esse fato e ele
disse olha nós decidimos que todo nosso
tempo a nossa energia ia ser a partir de
agora voltada para os nossos estudos o
nosso tempo está muito escasso para que
uma criança chega ao nosso lar neste
momento
e eu fazer um curso fora e estava entre
uma especialização ea graduação
concomitante e todo tempo que me sobrava
realmente era voltado para esse estudo
que para mim na ocasião foi e é muito
importante que a área que o ato hoje
bom então na sequência eu já disse para
pessoa muito obrigada mas eu estou em um
momento que eu não tenho condição de
fazer nenhuma visita e de fato a visita
não aconteceu
e o tempo passou decorreu mais ou menos
aí uns três anos e nós fomos a uma festa
de casamento né de amigos em comuns e
nessa festa quando nós chegamos em uma
igreja muito bonita muito arrumada nós
encontramos um outro casal de amigos
nossos que vieram não se encontram e a
linha uma conversa comum de amigos com
causas e etc
e esse casal nos disse olha existe uma
família que estão à procura de pais
adotivos
o e naquele momento alguma coisa algo
maior superior que a nós mesmos nos
tocaram de tal maneira que o casamento
aconteceu na sexta e no sábado lá
estávamos nós para essa tal visita para
essa visita que mudou o rumo da nossa
vida
e chegamos ao local e ali naquele
momento pela primeira vez nós somos pais
de duas crianças que estavam ali à nossa
frente a troca de olhares foi tão
diferente foi tão sublime foi tão
surreal que ali eu tive meu esposo
também a certeza absoluta que aqueles
gêmeos seriam os meus filhos
oi e aí no emoção muito grande levamos
dentro de um protocolo legal e ao
chegarem na nossa casa era como se eles
já tivessem convivido com a nossa
família desde o seu nascimento nessa
ocasião eles estavam prestes a completar
em três anos de idade mas o amor a
reciprocidade o envolvimento o carinho
que ele estava impregnado é como se eles
já fizessem de fato parte das nossas
vidas desde quando eles talvez
estivessem na barriga
é sim o tempo passou decorridos quatro
meses que aconteceu adoção aí nós
tivemos um maravilhosa surpresa um outro
telefonema nos disse olha eu estou aqui
muito emocionada a ponto de não
conseguir nem falar com você do que eu
quero tratar aí eu disse pois não eu não
a conheço ela disse meu nome é meire e
eu gostaria somente de lhe dizer que os
gêmeos que você adotou hoje são os
mesmos que nós havíamos lhe oferecido
quando eles tinham 9 meses
e ali naquele momento eu tive mais
certeza ainda que aqueles eram os meus
filhos que eles já tinham percorrido
algumas idas e vindas vamos considerar
assim em lares mas deus estava
programando para que eles estivesse ali
presentes para nós no tempo que fosse
correto
oi e a vinda deles ea chegada foi festa
para nossa família assim como é até hoje
é nós
e batalhamos estamos na luta até hoje
para conduzi-los para um caminho do bem
da retidão hoje eles são adolescentes né
então a gente tem muito orgulho de
contar essa história e eu
particularmente porque
e foi um processo triste doloroso foi
uma gestação que demandou dois anos e
três meses sem que nós estivéssemos
sabendo que se tratassem das mesmas
crianças e que depois tudo convergiu
para que realmente eles fizessem parte
da nossa família
tá bom não tem correr disso tudo né já
tinha que nós tínhamos feito adoção e
eles são muito conscientes de quase todo
o processo acontecido com eles sabem que
estão filhos adotivos tivemos sempre
essa transparência com eles tivemos
sempre o cuidado de tratar essa história
com muita leveza com muito amor com
muito carinho e o tempo passou matrícula
tudo certinho e com três anos que a
adoção aconteceu aí nós tivemos uma
outra surpresa eu agora estava grávida
naturalmente de um menino né então foram
três crianças são três crianças que são
de fato o que guia o que norteia a nossa
vida hoje então
e quando eu falei no começo que eu
gostaria né dispor sobre o amor eu acho
que adoção na verdade é o que retrata o
amor mais puro mais genuíno o que é um
amor estantanio que acontece sem você
conseguir de mencionar como aquilo ali
transforma não a sua vida mas a vida de
todo mundo que tá no seu entorno
a adotar significa amar
e eu tinha pensado de fazer esse
questionamento inicial mas isso é uma
verdade tão absoluta que eu não posso
fazer questionamento eu só posso fazer
afirmação adotar é muito maior do que o
mato de somente tem alguém legalmente ao
seu lado isso não significa adoção
adoção é por amor é vida adoção é você
transpor barreiras é você abrir mão de
coisas que até então eram muito
importante para você e que quando você
tem uma experiência dessa você entende
que todo todo o resto que todo demais é
muito pequeno é ínfimo diante do amor
que você pode dar e que você pode
receber em um laço que nada tem a ver
com conta sanguínea
a adoção é um laço de afetividade pura e
genuína
é o que eu posso dizer é que adotar
significa amar literalmente o amor de um
filho seja ele biológico do coração não
importa ambos são especiais ambos são
excepcionais não há como você mensurar
qual é o amor que têm maior ou menor
a validade condição eu vivenciou isso
esperem cio isso diariamente posso
atestar que amor é amor amor de mãe amor
de filho é amor não há o que questionar
e os meus filhos lucas matheus gêmeo
sons hoje fazem parte de uma ordem que
eles são membros estudam
o fazem esporte são pessoas que
conseguimos conduzir para um caminho do
bem para um caminho que nós embasamos
que nós ali cessamos estamos muito
felizes de ter podido nesse nesses 11
anos quase 12 dado a eles a chance de
amar reciprocamente amar sem ter que
cobrar nada de alguém e isso é eu acho
que é o que o que fica o que prevalece
é o amor de mãe por um filho é um amor
que não cabe no peito eu posso dizer que
é um amor sem defeito um amor programado
por deus é um amor genuíno como eu falei
ele se a moda como colo de mãe e eu
tenho orgulho vamos dizer assim de dizer
que meus filhos gêmeos que aos três anos
de idade não conseguiam falar nenhuma
palavra
e logo pouquíssimo tempo aprenderam a
seguinte frase pronunciar adotar
significa amar e eu tenho muito muito
orgulho de compartilhar essa história
com vocês muito obrigada